bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fuori j
oggi andiamo avanti con shaun the crush
eravamo rimasti che eravamo usciti da
chernobyl usciti tra molte fila di
virgolette e ci siamo sbloccati il
quarto livello che è la sventura di un
sorvegliante e indovinate un po chi è
questo fortunatissimo sorvegliante vabbè
è come al solito sono io il povero
sfigato che deve vagare nel buio a
cercare non so cosa va beh direi di
iniziare la gunn tra l'altro ci sono
incamiciato dalla testa ai piedi ma non
sapevo che mettermi scusate
ok ci siamo c'è un desktop fantastico
come sfondo me lo devo scaricare me lo
metto anch'io eh vabbè c'è un cappello
da carabiniere che cazzo succede
ok c'è qualcuno nel corridoio
probabilmente una donna che sta cercando
di comprare il latte
però quello non è un supermercato che
cazzo è successo
ok è c'è stato un black out si apre feo
kay come al solito raga black out non si
sa perché e tiriamo fuori la torcia come
al solito
ok ho messo il cappello da carabiniere
adesso vengo a farti la multa perché
perché sono un carabiniere vabbè
lasciamo stare
ok siamo partiti la gara episodio 4 sono
contentissimo di andarlo a giocare porca
[ __ ] che stasera ce l'ha pure
italia's got talent e io vado a giocare
a sta roba
ok ragala di lady d affrettarci
nell'uscire di qua se quello era il
ramen ok c'è anche fame tra l'altro
quindi lo prenderei volentieri ma vabbè
usciamo ok ragazzo ci siamo
stiamo per uscire nel corridoio prima
porta
ok devo prepararmi psicologicamente
perché ho deciso di registrare the
grudge e da un momento all'altro
permesso nessuno è perfetto
si inizia benissimo allora studio allora
ho sentito dei passi c'è nessuna non c'è
ok è il corridoio è veramente promette
benissimo
oddio mi devono le gare e trascinare di
forza per portarmi laggiù comunque qua
c'è una porta do not enter do not enter
per dirmi di non entrare devi scrivere
entra pure lo sai
allora noi siamo probabilmente nello
studio no noi siamo ok siamo qui in
basso a sinistra perché c'è l'icona alle
sorvegliante ok infatti c'è anche il con
la rossa che indica che siamo qua allora
questo a sinistra dovrebbe essere un
uscita in teoria presumo che non sia pro
questo presentimento infatti allora raga
siano costretti ad andare la george fa
chi è sono contentissimo ok si sia già o
dio che cazzo succede
cos'era quella cosa nella telecamera di
sicurezza dubito sia un impiegato a
quest ora ha dovuto anch'io
prima di tutto devo risolvere il
problema elettricità sono saltati anche
i telefoni
mi domando che cosa fosse quella cosa là
semplicemente una donna che cazzo è hero
non ho la più pallida idea di chi sia ma
è un altro membro della famiglia appunto
che diciamo sono sicuro che non fara una
bella fine comunque raga devo riuscire a
contenermi in questo episodio perché non
voglio che voglio cercare di essere meno
volgare possibile che cazzo succede
ok questa e multa per disturbo alle
scatole pubbliche
ok
poiché la faccio ricordami appena
travolto aquino li mortacci sua chi
cazzo è questa anche a lei e si metta
qualcosa addosso atti osceni in luogo
pubblico anche lei una multa ok
e tu che cazzo chacarita e quello chi
minchia è ok e buongiorno anche a lei è
vietato sostare nelle porte degli
ascensori
allora o lei si alza o appena torno sono
50 euro di multa per sosta vietata negli
ascensori i votacci tua sorella
ma che cazzo è ok ok ok che cazzo è
successo bene ci siamo ragazzi
proseguiamo bene è successo di tutto già
nei primi due minuti di gioco dietro non
mi vengono lasciato niente per ok
devo muovermi perché social net a
batteria e qui finisce la batteria
diciamo non è una bella sorpresa ragazze
una porta vetrata qui non è le porte
vetrate non mi prendo colpi perché ci
vedo quello che c'è poi nei corridoi
ok ciao come va tutto a posto
cerchi anche tu latte e anche perché
sono atti osceni in luogo pubblico qui è
allora fermo lì che arrivò a farti la
multa fermo li senti e sai per caso dove
la tipa che cercava al latte prima ok è
sparito ok bene è sparito c'era un
bambino
c'era un bambino fatemi salvare
maledizione ok
c'era un bambino vale detto eh vabbè io
tornerei indietro lì non ci vado c'è una
porta almeno aperta quindi
e più sicura diciamo sembra cosa che
luccica tra l'altro una batteria
la prima batteria ok c'è anche cos'è sta
roba
ci sono i detersivi ok faccio che prende
alla batteria batteria alcalino che
siamo uno e mezzo è già qualcosa
bene intanto li vedo il mastro lindo e
qui c'è anche un forno a microonde
peccato che non ho portato i sandwich
merda ci avevano anche fame bedi la cera
mense voglio comunque ma chi cazzo
comitato sul soffitto
questi non sono capelli o era mn scaduto
o non so che cos'è
ok tra l'altro perfetto è sparita la
ciocca bene che vero
amo the grudge e il mio gioco preferito
in assoluto porca [ __ ] chi l'ha
inventato dovrebbero dargli l'ergastolo
mio dio bene questa volta mi sono
spaventato un casino per una ciocca di
capelli o che un giorno è il latte non è
in questa corsia
ok si mia nonna cammina anche un po più
veloce comunque tra l'altro mi lamento
tanto le personaggio principale che
cammina lento ma minchia anche tu non
scherzi eh allora c'è il bagno dei
maschi cioè nessuno no perfetto permesso
è occupato se entrando vedete di non
fare rumori troppo diciamo sinistri
perché sto entrando sono fatte delle
figure di merda nel vero senso della
parola
ci sono dei capelli nel cesso ma con la
mia amica detto che questo non è un
parrucchiere
ok ho tirato l'acqua i capelli non vanno
giù però ecco multa per intasamento di
cessi pubblici maledizione quanta gente
che infrange la legge al giorno d'oggi
che cazzo è sta roba terra che cosa sta
facendo si sta girando da solo cosa
guardi
cazzo ok cazzo vai dentro maledizione ok
chiudi la porta bravo bravo la chiave la
chiave
ok c'è nessun sorella mia lavati piedi
perché non sei messa benissimo punta
cerchio con il telecomando wii perfetto
ok ok ok ok no no no no no no perfetti
madonna quanto sono impedito no perfetto
ci sono ci sono ci sono ci sono
bene ci siamo se n'è andata
se n'è andata ci siamo ragazzi ok piano
usciamo perfetto
via libera allora i bisogni tuoi file di
nel bagno delle ragazze perché nel bagno
degli uomini giustamente ci entrano gli
uomini non le donne brutta stronza
comunque c'era qualcosa qui a terra
appunto con codice pin 6 è una mezza
chiara sì probabilmente devo raccogliere
una chiave a frammenti ora colto primo
frammento perfetto
la porta si apre no perfetto riusciamo
perché io qui dentro non ci voglio più
stare bene non è successo niente di
strano che cazzo succede mi si blocca ok
non c'è nessuno perfetto mi stanno
crollando raga non c'è nessuno vedo
soltanto i riflessi che poi tra l'altro
non vedo il mio di riflesso vedo solo
suo ma dettagli non facciamo domande
usciamo da sto posto di merda che già
non lo sopporto ok madonna raiola giusto
iniziò ad odiarlo sto gioco vabbè che lo
diamo già dall'inizio però c'è più più
vado avanti più la cosa diventa sempre
peggiore ok ho sentito un rumore
stranissimo intanto li ci sono dei cap
no non sono capelli e del sangue ok
salve no non è il bambino è
semplicemente un manichino calmi
comunque
in questo gioco preferisco vedere sangue
i capelli se devo essere sincero però
entriamo qui dentro anche se la porta
vetrata quindi in teoria non ci
dovrebbero essere problemi entriamo è
permesso
sono qui per controllare che sia tutto a
posto cerco la donna che cercava al
latte prima sti cazzo di manichini prima
o poi li prendo a calci manco lo slider
fa così paura
ok salve
si ritenga fortunata che anche per lei
non attacchino intanto c'è qualcuno non
si dorme sugli scaffali altra multa
maledizione o qualcuno che rispetta la
legge c'è
ok cosa è un'orgia di gruppo
io scusatemi se vi interrompo continuate
pure non voglio darvi fastidio qualcuno
ha dimenticato un braccio lì un braccio
anche qui è una mano io devo soltanto
prendere questo frammento e poi me ne
vado frammento numero 9 perfetto mi
manca soltanto mezza chiave e poi ci
sono ma perché cazzo sto cavo mi dà un
fastidio della madonna cazzo ok ok ok ok
stronzo non mi prendi passata si sa
ancora se ho vinto io ho vinto io il
latte non te lo do neanche non ti dico
neanche dove si trova al latte brutta
stronza così impari oggi e ragga usciamo
di qui prima che mi venga un infarto
seriamente
io me ne vado me ne vado me ne vado me
ne vado e stato un piacere veramente
continuate pure come se io non ci fossi
io me ne vado
come si esce l'asta porta maledetta dai
ok
addio vive oramai ragazze ho perso
talmente anni di vita che penso che alla
fine di questo video mi verrà un infarto
se non prima ok direi di uscire siamo
già usciti appunto siamo a metà
corridoio e andiamo in fondo c'è quel
bambino delle palle di nuovo lì che cosa
ci fai nell'angolino del corridoio
brutto stronzo
la mamma non ti ha detto che non si
sosta nei corridoi comunque va bene
facciamo finta di niente c'è una porta
qui intanto che non ha la maniglia
quindi dubito che si possa aprire
infatti è che cazzo è quella roba che
cola odio ma che cazzo qualcuno si è
divertito coi pastelli qui non è che mi
fai una fan art perché veramente tra
cavi benissimo che i disegni comunque
beh madonna la mamma non ti ha detto che
esistono i fogli per disegnare perché si
è aperta la porta
ok è permesso
mi servirebbe l'ascensore anche a me
salve
buongiorno sei mica tu che hai fatto
tutto sto casino qui no perché è questa
e un'altra multa è guarda che si usano i
fogli ma io direi che ti incassi io ti
sto aiutando ti sto dicendo che si usano
i fogli tutti incassi pure mamma mia che
gente o non si può neanche più parlare
guarda qui che bordello combinato sempre
che è stato lui poi magari sto accusando
uno che non c'entra niente
comunque c'è una sigaretta c'è una
sigaretta accesa perché fammi fumare
qualcosa perché veramente c'è uno stress
addosso non la prende perfetto allora
meglio così c'è una batteria meno male
perché la mia sta andando letteralmente
a morire
vi ricordo che se finiscono le batterie
non è una bella sorpresa vi dico solo
questo
ok vediamo magari se riesco a prendere
un ghetto reid una roba del genere
perché c'è una sete della madonna
però non ho spiccioli dietro quindi
niente da fare
ok raga l'ultima porta ad aprire ok ci
sono perfetto è chiusa però perché non
la fa aprire devo aprire ok devo usare
la chiave
purtroppo raga la chiave non l'ho ancora
completata mi manca un pezzo e forse sto
anche dove trovarlo quindi raga torna
indietro un attimo ok ragazzi siamo
siamo tornati nella prima porta vetrata
quella che non avevo aperto
presumo che la chiave si trovi appunto
qui perché l'unica porta che non ho
controllato o adulto e soltanto caricare
un salvataggio vecchio perché le
batterie mi stavano andando a morire
e quindi niente poi dovrà ritornare
semplicemente li buongiorno voi
ok scusatemi se vado di fretta ma devo
trovare devo trovare una devo trovare un
frammento di chiave che mi manca c'è una
fotocopia 3 o dio si è accesa la
fotocopiatrice da sola mi stampi mikami
stampi mikal frammento verona che cazzo
stai fatto copiando ok raga a quanto
strano perché è partita da sola
ok ma che cazzo di foto è quella ok
sexta falsa fotocopiando roba a caso è
bene devo assolutamente trovare l'ultimo
frammento raga devo farlo spero che tra
l'altro spero che sia qui perché io ho
dato per scontato che fosse qui
eccolo lo vedo lo vedo lo vedo lo vedo
lo vedo lo vedo
ok ci siamo ragazzi siamo l'ultimo
frammento c'è una batteria e mezzo c'è
la dovrei fare dovrei riuscire a
cavarmela ma per poco
ok ci siamo ci siamo siamo a tre
siamo a tre se riesco a prenderlo
perfetto appunto con codice pin
ci siamo la chiave è completa possano
andare aprire la porta ok spero che non
ci sia nessuno non penso comunque che
spunti qualcuno adesso ok va beh direi
di tagliare finché non torno indietro no
no no no ok brava per vai di da brano
vai vai vai di la brava ok
meglio così nomi è spuntato addosso
quindi va benissimo c'è relativamente
bene nel senso che poteva andare meglio
se non compariva era meglio diciamo ok
ragazzi siamo sono tornato ho due
batterie piene è una terza che diciamo
un filo di batteria
siamo alla porta con il codice ok 926
perfetto possiamo entrare finalmente ok
sono contento perché mi lascio tutto
come posto alle spalle non ho idea di
che cosa ci sia oltre giustamente
permesso ci ho messo due ore per entrare
qui dentro quindi non fate scherzi a ma
questa è la stanza del generatore dove
possa accendere la luce credo ok ci
siamo scelta stone lo vedo già quindi
perfetto
ok ragazzi siamo allora accendiamo sta
roba e siamo a posto
credo sì perché si accenderà si è accesa
non ci posso credere che sia accesa ok
che cazzo ok perfetto come non vento non
sia acceso niente ma sono apparsi dei
capelli
perché ti stai guardando in giro se li
sta colando qualcosa
ok ok via indietro maledetto non sono
indietro anche no
ok madonna santissima ha visto la detta
portarli a prix dove cazzo andata che è
successo ok raga non c'è più è sparita
madonna manco houdini faceva sti trucchi
infatti raga me ne vado subito me ne
sbatto di che cosa c'è in sostanza anche
se dovrei avere attivato già cosa quindi
non dovrei fare più nulla ma me ne vado
ok non c'è nessuno perfetto
ok meno male cosa devo fare adesso che
attivato sta roba
raga io non ho capito sinceramente che
cosa è servito attiva sta roba perché io
pensavo si accendesse la luce che cosa
sta facendo
vai con rari brutto stronzo oddio ok ok
ok ok ok ok ok corri corri corri corri
corri corri corri corri
ma questo stronzo corri corri ok
oddio oddio dio dio dio dio dio ieri
anzi aggiuntivi ofa sporca [ __ ] aiuto
aiuto aiuto io odio l'ottenuta inventati
cazzo cazzo
ok ok ok ok
oddio sono diventato io 6 volt
all'improvviso ok
mio zio santissimo se n'è andata se n'è
andata vero
mio zio palazzo besta è stata assurda
minchia no non se n'è andata però ma che
cazzo ti fermi corri
non ci posso credere
può essere così [ __ ] che mi
sono cadute le cuffie porca [ __ ] a
cristo
porca [ __ ] sto sudando cazzo mi ha
fatto mamma mia che cosa assurge cazzo
di livello era questo ma no dai ma sono
esagerati si portò brogli minchia raga
devo riprendermi non posso mai passare
gli occhi così le serate ma che
sicuramente se un fifone soreta provaci
tu brutto stronzo non è andata fin dov'è
andato a finire lo spirito avventuroso
tipico dell'ariete nella nota fine ad o
dico io
la tua passività e beh in realtà un suo
fascino sì come al solito di guardare
ancora il video mica sto sudando raga io
dio
ho raccolto della roba non me ne frega
niente mica sono traumatizzato
allora ragazzi vi dico una cosa abbiamo
finito tutti gli episodi tranne uno c'è
un episodio speciale che mi devo
sbloccare per sbloccarlo devo
raccogliere tutti gli oggetti speciali
tipo letti per frammenti delle foto che
avete visto ad esempio in questo livello
dato che ci metterei dei secoli a farli
a prenderli tutti in giro
dovrei rifarmi tutti i livelli
praticamente e io non me li farò mai per
nessuna ragione al mondo
allora dato che c'è un emulatore della
wii perché i pavimenti lo sto giocando
con l'emulatore della wii cercherò un
salvataggio dove qualcuno ha sbloccato
appunto tutta la roba così almeno ci
posso giocare senza andare a giocarmi
tutti gli altri quindi raga questo in
teoria dovrebbe essere penultimo
episodio è l'ultimo episodio sarà
appunto mi avete me l'avete detto voi
nei commenti o queste cose le so perché
me l'avete le teme la dette qualcuno di
voi ho letto i commenti
è l'ultimo episodio sarà nella casa
abbandonata che di sicuro l'episodio più
spaventoso ancora più di questo perché
perché la casa abbandonata è l'unico
posto che è inerente al film di the
grudge e perché nel film di degrado c'è
appunto da casa praticamente dove sono
morti sia la ragazza che non è una
ragazza tutto meno che la ragazza è
quella che ci ha seguito prima e dove
c'è il bambino gatto che sono fratello e
sorella vabbè sono morti in quella casa
è praticamente l'unico luogo inerente
alla storia di the grudge è dato che io
ho visto tutti e tre i film conosco più
o meno la zona della casa e se l'anno
ricreata più o meno come nel film vi
posso assicurare che questi che avete
visto come episodi e non sono niente in
confronto quindi veramente devo armarmi
di defibrillatore e gli ho già adesso
sto morendo perché non c'è veramente il
cuore mi sta andando a mille però
vabbè basta cerco di calmarmi in attimo
va beh vi assicuro che finora non avete
visto niente in confronto all'ultimo
episodio ne sono sicuro che anche se
ancora non ho giocato e vabbè dai come
al solito se il video è piaciuto
lasciato un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come in ogni video
trovate nella descrizione
se non sei ancora city scrivete bene ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]